allez les chéris on va passer alors si
hier soir dans l'effet papillon s'est
plongée dans l'univers des femmes qui
rêvent de ressembler à barbie à ce que
vous avez rêvé de ressembler à quelqu'un
à barbie non non non mais est ce que
vous êtes
franchement est-ce que vous avez
quelqu'un qui nous a envie de ressembler
pour le sait khaled est persuadé qu'ils
ressemblent enrique et à mesure c'est
vrai gros sur de la hem recall les yeux
quand j'étais jeune vous ressemblez
enrique iglesias non sans déconner si à
les y chante un peu de henrique bailamos
palamos il me fait souvent je le vois
miroir et la paix dans son bureau il
n'est pas direct moi je vais ressembler
à un soir où les oliviers à ce que
j'adore aussi soit eddie murphy as well
as
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
puis la vie a décidé de me faire assure
l'état comme le mec ça fait 20 ans qui
vend son lait dit murphy hydrique
églises ainsi fait qu'une étape sur
blonde
daniel braud et valérie benaïm ya une
chasse à la perdrix à riga qui vous à
les transférer sur chasse et pêche
annonce comme ça sur les épaules
il a retiré six
[Applaudissements]
tous ces textes chirac fait bien
l'ambiance avec veulent tirer un coup
c'est tout
ah oui oui
00 00
j'y arrive chaud c'est bon mr bean
[Applaudissements]
selon j'ai pas envie de faire tpn êtes
monsieur série mercy avec la boue nous
vous nous appelez nous de paris par le
boulogne encore vous faites quoi dans la
vie
journaliste d'accord à savoir le break
et prenait 2 mais ça passera moins vite
ferté pmp j'avais un peu trop couper les
cheveux longs abon à l'ats sans déconner
sur la valeur il rêve d aller jouer dans
la guerre des boutons c'est surya jeune
fille apparemment le blouson veut pas
passer en soit passé ne passeront pas le
pirate des caraïbes c'est le pirate des
caraïbes au jeu s'appelle aboisso
voulais ressembler tu le voulais mais
j'adore mais il ya un truc
oui un petit truc léger moi j'aimerais
vous et daniel bachelet ressembler annie
cordy ce que c'était elle et je voulais
faire rire tout le monde
pourquoi chaque fois que vous parlez
vous me déprimer j'aime bien nicoli mais
bon on aura passe partout
et vous êtes beaucoup mieux oui à ma
mère non eh bah écoute et bah bravo on
embrasse qu'elle s'appelle a demandé de
passe partout
[Applaudissements]